we have a voicemail number and that
number
is 219 to david p
here is a voicemail i got from someone
brutally calling me out
uh for things they maybe misunderstood
let's take a listen
david i'm a member this is tim
from california i am outraged because
you said
that plumbers make 40 000 per year
no try like i don't know i think they
make like a hundred thousand
no no no no no so what i i referenced
joe the plumber joe the plumber was
known
for during the 2008 election between
barack obama and the late senator john
mccain
coming out and saying plumbers like me
are going to end up paying a lot more in
taxes under barack obama's plan
and framed in that was the idea that he
had a plumbing business from which he
made
250 000 a year because
if he didn't make 250 000 a year he
wasn't going to pay any more under
barack obama's plan
we later found out he didn't even own
that he was like thinking of buying the
plumbing business or something like that
and he made far less money so i didn't
mean to suggest plumbers make
40 grand when i specifically said joe
the plumber
the point was he didn't make 250 000 he
wasn't going to be subject to more tax
under obama and he wouldn't be subject
to more tax
uh under under joe biden that was the
point let's continue
and that's according to google too
and bill nye isn't a scientist
he's technically a mechanical engineer
an actor and i mean i love bill nye but
he's um
he shouldn't be called a scientist
technically when did i last even mention
bill nye i don't even know why someone's
coming to me with bill
did i mention bill nye and just forget
it's very strange in any case
you can call the voicemail number
anytime you want 219
to david p i prefer that you comment on
things i've
actually said very often the right-wing
trolls call in
and attack me brutally for things they
must have heard on some other show
because they're certainly not things i
talked about i don't know but 2192 david
p
is that number we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today
the aclu is facing a sort of identity
crisis it was at one point simply known
as
the bastion of free speech but the aclu
has been in some weird situations lately
i have a personal story to mention about
this that i'll tell you guys about
that's on today's bonus show
california has approved a pilot program
for driverless vehicles driverless rides
and many people are excited others are
going completely crazy as if the sky
were falling we will talk about
that on today's bonus show and also the
fda has approved
an obesity drug that has helped some
people drop a significant amount of
weight
but there are some who believe that it
is not a fair
drug it is not a fair drug because it
could allow people
to have an unhealthy lifestyle and diet
and still lose weight and under the
paradigm of strict father morality that
would be
wrong very very wrong so we'll talk
about that on today's bonus show
as well get instant access to the bonus
show
by signing up for a membership at
joinpackman.com
or make a patreon pledge at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i will speak to you then